hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at renderer API
abstraction check out that video if you
haven't already we basically just pulled
out a bunch of our code into specific
classes that were kind of / render API
so we're dealing with OpenGL at the
moment so we created like an OpenGL
vertex buffer and index buffer class
that was specific specifically for
dealing with those kind of render api
like primitives or just things
essentially in a way that was kind of
abstracted out where when we kind of
call it from our application or from our
game kind of code or from our render
occurred it doesn't care which API is
actually used under the hood so
definitely check out that video if you
haven't already we're gonna kind of
continue down that slope today but we're
specifically gonna talk about buffer
layouts and when I say buffer layouts I
mean I'm really talking about vertex
buffer layouts okay we touched on this I
mean we've touched on this on my channel
just in general because of course you
can't really render anything without
having to deal with vertex buffer
layouts we have a video specifically
about that in the OpenGL stories or I'll
try and link it up there and definitely
check that out if you haven't already
and in general if you're not familiar
with the OpenGL stories I would just
take a look at pretty much all of it
because that's really gonna help you out
with what we're kind of building here at
this moment in hazal and also I'm gonna
I want to continue that OpenGL stories
probably next week when we throughout
this kind of next week because it's it's
again it's gonna be really important in
kind of taking a deeper look at some of
these concepts that we're learning here
in the game engine series so anyway
today we're gonna talk about Baja layout
so what does that mean why why do we
need them what do they do and how do we
write them in a way that is both
abstract and works for every render API
but also is actually kind of easy for us
to use because that's kind of what I'm
all about right I want the code that we
write on the client side the code that
we actually write like inside our game
kind of project right or inside our
renderer to just be beautiful
that's kind of what I go for that's what
I aim for right and it's actually
getting dark outside because I left this
video pretty late today I was just
planning and just making sure that I had
everything
that I wanted to say freak it out
because I really like I'm really I
really wouldn't want to do this well
this specific episode what all video is
really come on but you know this
specific episode so if it kind of gets
dark I'm sorry because it is like the
sun's gonna set in half now anyway the
point is beautiful code right I think
that's really important I think that if
the code that you're writing if you
design an API and the code that you're
writing just looks disgusting or just is
hard to do things with or isn't concise
enough that's an issue right think about
writing documentation or just writing
like an English essay or something like
that right if you take paragraphs
paragraphs and paragraphs to kind
describe the same thing and use can't
make really like nice kind of flowing
sentences that doesn't really sound nice
it's not good for the Raiders frayed and
it ended just apart from that not just
like it's just not nice aside from that
it's just not like actually practical
isn't doesn't work as well right like
the person might have to read your
sentence multiple times well they might
have to read a whole much more
information that they otherwise would
have to understand what it is you're
trying to say in your English essay
right and of course English essay is
you're probably going for a high work
cow anyway so you might just reiterate
stuff over and over again but encourage
that's really not the the case usually
like you actually are trying to be
concise right and just in general you
want to use kind of grammar and
sentences that both kind of sound nice
kind of in your essays writing your
English essays back to this but also
stuff that actually gets your point
across very just concisely and just
nicely so that the person can wants to
keep reading and that so that the person
forms a good visual kind of mental image
of what it is you're trying to do and
everything is just beautiful and
everything just feel solid that's what
we want to achieve with all of the api's
in this engine right that is what we
want to do that's not easy to do right
but because we're using a language like
C++ it's extremely flexible and it
actually means that we can do a lot of
what we're trying to do and today
specifically with Buffalo's I'm gonna
show you how there's probably there's
omits many different ways of essentially
doing the same thing but I want to do it
in a way that actually looks good
like we're talking about a buffer layer
we should just be able to visualize the
code and be like I get everything right
I get everything like we don't want some
weird like what like weird kind of way
of writing code for this Buffalo out
where it just doesn't make sense or it
just requires us to really think about
what it is we're defining no we want it
just to be easy we want it to just be
really easy because if it is easy and if
it is just so nice right and elegant
then apart from just looking good and us
feeling good about ourselves and also
other people dealing with us and being
like isn't this great this is so easy
apart from that it's also actually going
to reduce the bugs in our code
why because everything just makes sense
and if something is wrong we can
intuitively kind of just pick up on that
we don't need to just read the
documentation be like yeah I guess
that's wrong no we can just see the
errors right there because it's laid out
in such a way where errors are obvious
okay that's what we're gonna talk about
today we're gonna jump in and we're
gonna take a look at just the practical
example of what we actually have as well
as talk about what it is we're trying to
kind of create and I think that that's
really important when you kind of talk
about any kind of API that you want to
design or any kind of complex concept
it's what is this actually doing right
and with vertex buffer layer
specifically it's very simple you know
what we're doing is we're actually
telling OpenGL this byte array of data
what's in it how is it broken down you
know how many elements are there how
many like what are the elements you know
is this a three component vector of
floats right or is just three separate
floors you know is this a four kind of
component color houses specified is just
just maybe it's just an unsigned integer
you know or maybe it's four separate
floats or something like that right it
could be just absolutely anything like
if it's just a binary blob of data which
is what alpha takes buffer actually
takes in and uploads into the GPU we
need some way to actually describe the
layout of that data which again means
you know the first four bytes might be a
float the second four bytes might be
another floor and then the third four
bytes might be another float that's
three floats in a row that's our three
component vector that describes our
vertex position stuff like that that's
what we're trying to achieve let's try
and do it in an elegant way let's jump
in take a look
practical example and we'll see how we
go okay so last time I had this sum
triangle today we're gonna basically aim
to achieve the same thing but a lot more
elegantly and specifically we're also
gonna maybe jam in some other vertex
attributes for fun just to kind of see
how they work maybe we'll John well
maybe we'll just throw in a vertex color
or something like that let's just close
this sir
currently we are actually specifying a
buffalo out right if we weren't we
wouldn't see anything on the screen and
that's this right here okay these two
lines of code what is this saying is
inside our vertex buffer this one that
we're creating we have at index zero
three floats right they're not
normalized the stride between each
vertex is that size so three floats 12
bytes and the offset of this particular
element is nothing right now
I I don't really want to discuss how
this works too much because I do have an
OpenGL video about it and as I said the
Sun is setting and I have like other
stuff to do with my life and I don't
want to sit here for two hours just
reiterating wasting your time just
describing everything that I already
have already so definitely check out
that video but know that I don't know
like that that's this is like it might
be any quite simple at all to understand
so if you don't understand this
particular line of code make sure you
check out that video because I'm not
gonna really talk about it too much I
think it is in this episode so a few
things that I actually want to point out
what this particular line of code is I
guess the linkages of it so what it's
referring to what it's linked to how
what a corresponds to right so vete
Satrapi's pacifically are actually
stored in the vertex array not the
vertex buffer now they describe data in
a vertex buffer however a vertex array
is kind of the parent type if you will
um and a vertex array can contain
multiple buffers right we can actually
interleave our buffers and have you know
just in this one vertice like right in
this one what kind of vertices array we
could just add you know we want a vertex
color or vertex normal or something we
can actually just add it like just BAM
like that you know and that way you know
everything every single vertex that we
have is kind of going to contain in this
case maybe both a position and a normal
right
or the other thing we could do is kind
of just not interleave it so not have
any of this right but then just make
another kind of array here right another
float array which has had vertex normals
and then we can actually upload that
into a separate vertex buffer we can
create another vertex buffer just for
the normals and then another one for the
colors and another one for you get that
you get the point right so because of
that opengl doesn't really care how you
do that you can interleave all your data
and have one big fat vertex buffer which
is pretty much what you want like 99% of
the case by the way or you can split up
your vertex buffers into separate kind
of actual vertex buffers and separate
buffers of memory and then upload them
individually it doesn't matter because
this stays the same right it's just you
having to bind different vertex buffers
and certain times when you actually
describe your vertex array and will kind
of maybe talk about that in the next
episode because next episode we're going
to talk about vertex arrays and actually
abstracting them out into a class which
means this kind of stuff anyway what I
want you to know is that this particular
binding this kind of I'm enabling a
vertex a trip array and specifying look
at the layout of my buffer that is
stored in a vertex array if I bind
another vertex buffer or something like
if I don't need to re define this all I
need to do is this stuff get this state
gets saved into my vertex array if I
want to recall it for rendering I just
simply bind my vertex array again and
it's done okay the second piece of
information is that this is directly
tied to our shader right if we look at a
shader like we've specified one here
look at this layout location equals zero
back three a position right and that
that's this piece of data written by a
vector right three floats that's what a
vector E is right non-normalized three
times the size of floats or 12 bytes
again the size of this type index 0
layout equals 0 rather location equals 0
right that is what that's tied in with
if we suddenly want to take in a normal
right we put that in location 1 let's
just go with the color in this case
because it's a different type a Veck 4
and this will be our kind of vertex
color right what do we do we duplicate
this right we have it at index 1 and by
the way we also
to enable it so enabling index one we
have four floats and then the rest is
kind of the same except this changes
because that is oh and this is wrong by
the way sorry this isn't decisive I
should visit the stride so it's actually
the size of each vertex not the size of
each element right so it's kind of the
size between each vertex in the array so
if you if we have three vertices it's
the size of each full vertex which would
be the size of both the position and the
color in this case which would actually
be seven times size of float and that
would be the same for both of them so
this this changes to this right and then
the offset is the offset of this
particular element right inside the
buffer so obviously this is back a back
3 that's 12 bytes three floats right 12
bytes so the offset of this is going to
be 12 so it's simply 12 right and we
just need to cast it to a positive ROI
pointer okay okay so that's kind of what
we end up with but you can see that it's
directly tied to my shader that's the
kind of the point that I want to drive
home right here is it's tied to my
shader okay and it's actually not really
tied to shaders in OpenGL in the sense
that there's no validation performed
between that indirect tax it is
absolutely performed right you cannot
describe a vertex buffer until you've
bound a shader okay
so it's actually a bit different than
how OpenGL works anyway that's kind of
my point so because it's so heavily tied
with my shader what I actually want to
kind of do for my buffer layout is I
basically just want to be able to set a
buffer layout on to a vertex buffer
right now I did just say that they're
tied to vertex arrays however but a
layout describes a vertex like a layout
is specific to a vertex buffer it
describes a layout of an actual buffer
of memory so whilst OpenGL kind of
stores the state in vertex array in
DirectX there specifically on vertex
buffers because there's no such thing as
a vertex array indirect tax but apart
from that it just makes it just makes
more sense to us so it doesn't to us it
doesn't really matter that they actually
stored inside vertex arrays because we
can still kind of work around that
and store them wherever we like it's
just that in the end under the hood will
make that differentiation when we need
to but the kind of surface level API
should still set it onto the vertex
buffer now how do I describe this layout
well there's a lot of ways that you
could do it but I'm not gonna waste your
time and show you all the bad ways of
doing it I'll just show you a nice way
of doing it which is again what I'm
talking about where we want to kind of
have an elegant visual representation of
this wouldn't it be cool if when we kind
of described this layout because somehow
literally just have this kind of code
like right here and just be like you
know our layout equals kind of maybe put
this in brackets our layout equals like
that all right now let me just I just
realized I've got white spaces on which
mean don't need wouldn't it be nice if
we could just do something like that
well that's kind of what we're gonna do
we're gonna actually literally make it
so that we can see a visual
representation of our layout so our goal
is to have something that's maybe called
a buffer layer class right which is
going to look like this and then maybe
what we'll have is each element is going
to be kind of defined like this okay and
we're gonna achieve this by just using
an initializer list and probably
destroying these elements in a vector
now we're not going to use it back three
or back four there's a GLM types in this
case one here they're obviously open G
and the GLSL types inside the OpenGL
shading language but what we're actually
gonna do is come up with some kind of
enum that describes this datatype so
we're essentially gonna probably create
like an enum class called like shaded
datatype which will be kind of our cross
api cross-platform way of just kind of
defining each data type that is inside a
shader so like in fact three back for
you know floor it into that kind of
stuff so we'll probably use something
called like float three to describe a
three component thing you know Veck
three is cool and all but I kind of like
float three that's kind of the hlsl
style way of doing things and we are
probably going to eventually switch to
HLSL shaders you can use vector e if you
want because that's kind of tied to our
math library and like at the moment
but I'm just gonna use flow three to
describe a three-component flow okay
because it makes sense and then we'll
probably give it a name now you don't
really need to give it a name it's
useful to give it a name like indirect
text we will have to supply some kind of
string as you'll find out in the future
but it's just nice to kind of give it a
name just so that you know what this
actually is and if you want you can
actually call it the same thing which is
what I'm kind of doing in this case so
it might have that let's just get rid of
this whole color thing I mean
essentially you did the same thing for
call it though you just make FX like a
float for and do all that and that will
that's gonna look really nice right
we'll get her to color here and we'll
get rid of this stuff changes back to
three floats and we'll try and just ran
it that triangle to begin with okay so
this is my layout um and I'll set my my
layout and that's kind of it that's
actually how I wanted to find my layout
and you can see that it becomes really
nice because suddenly if I have a layout
that's full of like stuff that I need
you know like you know we might have
like texture coordinates or something
and you know you have something like
text cord and maybe normals and then you
might have like color or anything it's
just so easy to see the layout of this
buffer right it's amazing that's all I
need to do and obviously if I want to
like have an array of things like you
know if I wanted to be normalized or not
I can maybe add a third parameter but
this is kind of what we're going for
so let's take a look at the magic to
make this happen so I'm going to define
all this code inside the buffer file
here because it is to do with buffer
layouts and all that stuff so I'm gonna
make a class called buffer layout okay
and a buffer layer is essentially going
to contain a vector of buffer elements
okay and these are going to be called
elements I'm immediately just going to
give it a get up to return that because
we we are going to need that so get
elements on stand that will return
elements again and then these buffer
elements are going to be another class
actually I'll pull this a struct buffer
elements
and this is going to contain all of the
stuff that we need to actually specify
okay so the first thing it will contain
is a name so a silly-string name I mean
in no particular order we need the
offset we need the size we need what
else do we need
the counts I guess because we can have
like multiple of these I'm not really
sure if we need that to be honest
because I'm just thinking about it like
we definitely need that for uniforms if
we have like an array but we don't
generally I think if we just have that
shaded data type as I said which is
going to be the type of data will kind
of know the count of how many elements
we have anyway and we can always create
helper functions to kind of compare
between the two right so we'll maybe
have the name the type the size and in
the offset and I think that should be
enough right now the way that we
constructed this over here was just by
writing the type first right and then
the actual name so we can actually do
that here as well we just need to create
a constructor that allows that kind of
construction all right
so I'll write cons to a CD string name
and then shade a datatype type all right
and then over here we will set
everything so name will set to name the
type we all set to type size will set to
zero to be our size we can calculate
pretty much immediately I think because
that's just the size of the type so we
probably don't need to set that although
we can here as a default and then offset
we'll set a zero offset we can really
only calculate once we have context so
offset is going to be the offset of this
element in our inside our layout so
obviously to calculate the offset we
need to be aware of all the elements in
there because if this is like the second
element its offset is gonna be the size
of the first element right because
that's how that's how much into the
buffer it is so we currently calculate
that just yet but we can't calculate the
size so we might do that anyway in um
class
dadada type right and we can make this
like I mean if you wanted to you could
make this like you and a tea or
something just tiny because it doesn't
really need to be very big literally it
doesn't really matter you know
I'm not I'm not one to just like this
isn't gonna be serialized this is not
like maybe if it comes down to us trying
to really pack this daughter entirely we
can do that in the future but you don't
need to in the like the time being so
I'll have none will have floor it would
have flowed to will have flowed three
will have flirt four
we'll have you spoken to like mat three
mat for this is not just going to
describe attributes by the way it can
describe everything will have int will
have in 2 into 3 into 4 yeah it's
probably good enough for my topic struct
or something for like uniforms well
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there okay that looks pretty good to me
there's a good like basic type you can
have boolean's as well maybe I was right
pool at the end here okay that's pretty
pretty good right so that describes all
of our types now two things I'm
concerned about as a size and also the
[Music]
the offset which we can calculate in a
minute so what we can do is create some
kind of function obviously the converts
between this kind of shader data type
and an actual size so what we can do is
just create a static you into 32t shader
dot it you know we just do share data
type size I guess get advantage size
share the data type type and then this
will simply my letter e seems a pattern
just like contacted without pressing
hard this is just gonna be a switch the
same this is just going to be a switch
statement that goes between the
basically two switches on every single
type that we have associated data type
you know in the port and in this case
you know it just kind of I don't know
two three four four now this just
returns the size of it so a float is
four bytes is no return that much and
will also kind of do the same for pretty
much everything else so a float two
three four mat three mat for I'm gonna
try and be comprehensive usually I like
adding these things as like your just
because this just takes in a little is
just takes a bunch of time and makes the
video more complicated but I'll do it at
least for this for now because it
shouldn't take too much time
alright I think that's it so all of
these right you just align these a bit
okay so float two is gonna be four times
two four three is gonna be times three
times four right a matte three is gonna
be times three times three right because
the 3x3 matrix a float for is gonna be
the same but four by four matrix and
it's gonna be four you know in it it's
gonna be and in two is gonna be that
that you guys gonna get the point and
then it bulls probably I'm not sure I
might be one by my before we'll see
about that but we'll just leave it as
one for now and obviously we'll return 0
if we have nothing and also we should
definitely set here pour assert false
unknown shader unknown shared a data
type okay
and we don't need to print out the type
if it's a week that'll just break here
and we can just inspect it using the
debugger ourselves okay there we go
that's everything I hopefully I didn't
make any mistakes I was kind of high
school here but now we can actually see
what the type of each piece of data is
right now this is in buffer remember
when we actually move this into shaders
and have more stuff we'll deal with that
kind of then okay cool
right so what we want to do now is
actually calculate that size right so it
right here in size we can already just
call shader data type size and then pass
in the type all right and then we have
that beautiful now and this is just
buffer element of course not buffer
when we create a buffer layer right what
we want to be able to do is take in and
initialize a list right so this kind of
thing now this this is interesting
because ultimately you could just say I
can take you and I just want to take in
like a constant vector right because if
you take in a vector and it doesn't
matter if it's constant reference or
whatever that let it ease annoying me it
doesn't matter if it's Const reference
or whatever but if you take that in like
this kind of should work it doesn't
because there's two implicit costs
happening but just say that you know you
know if we just take this type
technically speaking and we change that
and make it this type right that will
actually work right so you you can
actually construct something like this
now it's not working this yeah we've
kind of put this the wrong way around I
don't know how I did that so easily as
well so we put the type first and then
the name in actual list here so if we
get rid of this and go back it should
work again there we go see and then what
you can do is actually decide that I
want to make a layout layout from my
layout right currently pull this out but
whatever you get the point right but
unfortunately I can't just do this okay
because it there's one implicit cost to
convert a vector like an initializer
list into a vector and another implicit
cars to convert the vector into a buffer
layer because buffalo has a constructor
that takes in vector so we can't
actually do that what we can do however
is actually just take in and initialize
a list here right and then if we
actually do that right then you know you
can do like your constants here if we do
that you can see this works okay
beautiful so now we basically got
exactly what we wanted which is pretty
cool and then from this right how do we
convert into a vector well as I said
there's obviously a constructor for
vector that takes in an initializer list
so we literally just do I guess I'll do
maybe layout or elements we'll call it
just like that okay there we go so now
we can construct one of these from here
and all of the data that we've actually
said
is inside this vector which is very cool
now once we have that vector we actually
need to calculate the offsets so I'll
say calculate offsets and there's one
more piece of this one more piece of
information that we need and that is the
stride and the stride is the size of
each vertex each complete vertex so all
of the attributes the size of all of
those together
that's only known after we had the whole
list same as the offset right so we can
calculate that once we have the whole
list we can't do that inside buffer
element but we can do that here so we'll
make au and 32t called M stride which
will set a zero by default calculate
offsets and stride will be a beautiful
function that we have here that's going
to be private private so void calculate
offsets and stride that's going to go
through all the lists all the elements
that we have here so I guess we'll just
say for order reference elements in this
letter is really annoying me in elements
right and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna maintain an offset here and then I
guess we can set m stride its to 0 equal
to 0 here just in case we recalculate or
something this is what we're gonna do
we're just gonna say that the element
offset right is gonna be our offset then
we're going to say offset plus equals
element dot size right and then we're
also gonna say M stride plus equals
element size okay so that she said all
the offsets and all the and and also
calculate the stride for our entire buff
allowed that's I think that's about it
to be honest what haven't we done I
think everything's well I don't know we
should just check it out and see if it
works so we haven't automatic office
that layout we'll do that in a second
I'll just put a breakpoint here I
launched this and see if that layout is
everything that we want it to be and
more potentially I should probably add
something else that it'll out because
it's just you know I mean this is gonna
be pretty boring I think we just have
one thing in in there but if we take a
look
so our layout has one element that's
right of 12 which is correct and the
position has an offset of zero size of
12 okay looks good let's just to test it
a bit more I'm gonna add two more things
I'm going to add a foot another foot
three and then I'll float for maybe I'll
put the foot four in the middle just to
make it a bit different so we'll pretend
that we have normal in the color we'll
see what that looks like okay that okay
I was gonna say to compile but that's
because we put the comma in the wrong
place let's just try again here
okay so layouts I struck this write as
40 is that correct
so 16 plus 12 plus 12 yeah that's
correct 20 24 plus 16 size is 3 and
these should have correct offsets offset
of 12 and offset of 28 beautiful okay so
there we go
allow clearly works and that is really
cool so now let's try and render
something with it what I want to do is
go into our buffer class right do a
buffer file and just add you know a
virtual void set layout all right buffer
layouts I'll take that in as a
constructor and layout equals 0 and then
we'll also have a virtual const buffer
layout and get layout
so I want to be able to get and set the
layout right we'll open up GL vertex
buffer or rather GL buffer and inside
here these should all be overrides by
the way not sure why they're not because
I was lazy I guess so now we're gonna
have Const override for all of these and
these two will get layout so when a
still the layout here so we'll have buff
allow em lay up and layouts get lay up
is just going to return it and thank you
Visual Studio for that or in this
formatting and then this is just gonna
set it right so M layout equals layout
make but these yeah that's fine okay
done so there we go I was gonna make
them in line but there's no point that
is done now we should be able to just
rock and roll with this now as I
mentioned this particular code is get it
gets set in the vertex array we'll talk
about that next video because we haven't
abstracted that just yet so now we'll
just do that stuff here and you'll kind
of see how it works but in the next
episode we'll move it into the
appropriate location
I could that end the episode here but
I'm not going to just cuz I actually
want to see this stuff in action and
rendering and I did promise you guys
vertex colors okay so to make this stuff
work what I need to do is iterate
through every element in the layout now
I could write code such as you know for
Const order elements inside layout get
elements but I don't want to I just want
to write code like this because it just
looks better so I'm buff away out what
I'm gonna do to make that happen is the
same thing that we did inside layout if
you remember which is we're actually
sorry inside layer stack where I
actually provided iterators beginning in
so if we copy this code and then go in
to buff up the inside buffer layout and
get elements I can just provide an
iterator here obviously in this case
it's gonna be a buffer element instead
of a layer and then this is gonna be M
elements begin and
and and then there we go okay so now we
can just do that which just looks nice
so we're iterating through every element
in the layout and we just want to do
this kind of stuff here so we'll keep
track of which index were up to all
right could have just use a regular for
loop just that has that built in but
this is also fine what's that the index
here and then we'll increment the index
now this is where it gets interesting
okay so what we need for OpenGL is we
can't just say that it's a vector e we
have to say that it's actually three
floats we have to say the time and then
the count as if it's like not one
variable now interact X you don't you
don't do that you just say you know this
is a focal partner vector this is a
three component vector or two component
vector so that's why like I don't that
that's why I haven't written this in a
way that is just like you know type and
count as if we have type being float and
then count being three that's weird
I don't like doing it that way and
DirectX doesn't want it that way anyway
so what we need here is some kind of
conversion to take place so it'd be nice
if just regardless elements just had a
component count right because that will
just make that work so let's go back
into buffer and actually just add that
in so buffer element will make a little
probably some kind of get component
count thing here right we can probably
like I'm not sure what the best way to
do this would be I guess I don't think
is gonna be called often enough for us
to catch that and ruin the kind of you
know sort of memory that'll be annoying
so maybe we can just say get elements
count and then we can maybe just do some
kind of switch yeah I'm just thinking
about this yeah it's probably fine if we
just um left comes here and then we'll
switch on the type here and we'll say
that if we have a shader type
floor three will just return great okay
and that is the component cat what do
you know water ten zero here any asserts
saying that we have an unknown type
again this shouldn't really happen ever
but it might and I guess because I'm a
good person even though I said I
probably wouldn't will fill out the rest
of these so we'll start with float then
we'll have float two three four then int
oops two three four what else we have
Matt Matt for and stuff okay sure no
more probably don't need Matt 4 and not
3 to be completely honest with you
because it's Lana Lee's gonna be well I
don't know this is the component
calculator it's not gonna be used just
for attributes so we might need that
and then I've it everything I get will
humble that's obviously one that's four
that's three that's true
that's one am at four is going to be
four times four not three is gonna be
three times three flat for twenty four
to one all right now looks pretty good
to me let's just tap this across and
let's kind of try and align this some
watch just so that it looks nice and
there we go okay cool
so there we go now we can put the
element count
sorry not element counts this is gate
component count
okay so just just how many components
essentially we have here now
unfortunately we also need so we've got
the component count but we also need the
actual OpenGL type and this is like the
base type we don't we can't have like
vector e we need specifically flirt so
we also need something that figures that
out now I don't really like the type
that we actually have obviously is
inside our element and it is like our
like you know we have like element type
essentially that's our shader data type
so what I'm gonna do is write a function
up here that's obviously not gonna live
here forever it's gonna be called will
have it return a you will have a return
a GL email which is what that type I
guess what the vertex the trip pointed
parameter actually expected the type to
be and will say shader datatype to
OpenGL base type in case is gonna be
conversion between the shader data type
to the opengl base type so again we'll
have a switch statement on type oh my
gosh did that for me that's pretty cool
might actually after - oh love it now I
wasn't planning to this is the one this
is the one time I was planning on not
actually doing all of these but I guess
I will have to know so in this case you
know we're gonna just return jail flow
and that's actually gonna be the case I
think for a lot of these so this
included right and you you weren't
always need this function but you do
sometimes need it and I guess for that
for that it's fine so does this ends and
we haven't dealt with unsigned ends but
you know if we really want that in the
future then we can just do that in the
future okay I don't know if you know
we'll just have a ball I guess I don't
really know because this isn't something
that we do all day so unknown that and
wonder 10 0 okay cool so there we go so
now what we can do is actually go over
here and say that we have shader data
type to OpenGL base type and that's how
we get out you upload now whether or not
it's normalized again really easy to do
elements dots normalized oh my gosh I
forgot about normalization didn't I
normalized so if that's true then we'll
do GL true I knew I forgot something
otherwise you're false okay this pride
obviously is going to be lay out not
element that lay out dot stride don't
get stride I thought I'd did that
probably not
and then the offset is going to be
elements dot offset okay and will cost
this to a constable pointer
alright bit hard to see because it's
pretty big but there we have our huge
line of code which I probably should
break into multiple lines that I guess I
will break it up into multiple lines
just so you guys can see all of it so
we're gonna have all this stuff I guess
every parameter on a separate line just
like that okay
and normalized so we need to add that so
buffer will normalized which again like
I don't know we'll just have it as false
by default and no real way to set it for
now but we might have a constructor I
mean look let's just be nice let's just
say bull well I'm actually try it this
will work with initializer lists but if
we just do that does that work yeah
that's the works cool so we can now
optionally specify whether or not this
is normalized so normalization is good
for if you're supplying like a like a an
unsigned int essentially and you want it
to automatically convert it into a back
for of like floats um it can actually do
that you just say that you're supplying
an int and that it's needs to be
normalized and you'll get that this has
no member called guess tried yeah so
what you can do now is if something were
to be normalized you could just do that
right and again not sure yes you
wouldn't do that here but if you have
like a color is it
that's not signed in we can actually try
that out you know why not um I'm feeling
a bit adventurous today I'm feeling like
actually doing stuff even though this
video is dragging on anyway I'll stop
talking so gets tried we need to add
that
so we have stride in line you enthuse
you t get stride const return m stride
alright I think that's it like if I hit
a five now it should probably work let's
just try oh and we haven't set the
layout that's a we don't have to
technically speaking because we're just
writing it from here anyway we have a
compiler
okay notable constructors that's a good
point
so we need to add default constructors
for all of these right buffer element
because they need to be initialized and
buffer layout now you could be less lazy
with this and actually give your your
things default parameters it works for
here it doesn't work for here I'm not
gonna bother for now okay let's hit f5
and see what happens okay look at that
we have our triangle how cool is that
that's really cool we had that last time
as well let's try and um and actually
add a color now so what I'm gonna do is
inside my layout just add a new flirt
for it's going to be my color and then
I'm going to go into the shader and and
layout location equals one in effect for
color okay I'm not going to use it for
now let's just see if this even works
right in fact I don't even have to add
it here let's just keep that out for now
I might just take it out at the end so I
can undo it and but everything should
work here the only thing we need is
actually everything here so let's
specify color let's just make this thing
pink I guess this will say 1 0 1 1 right
that's kind of pink magenta so every
vertex will be that color and then we
can probably interplay between them in a
minute as well just to see how that
looks like but for now we'll start with
pink which means we now have I guess 7
elements per vertex everything should be
calculated automatically though that's
the beauty of this and if we take away
this I'm we should just get exactly the
same result this last time even though
our vertex buffer has more stuff in it
hopefully everything else did not need
changing look at that we still get our
triangle even though I bet X bar is
different clearly this stride and the
offsets are working correctly otherwise
it wouldn't you
we would read the next three vertices as
being this and our triangle would look
different let's bring back the color and
actually set the color inside our case
we need to keep this to the fragment
shader
so we'll say out that for the color copy
that paste that here call it in back for
V color and then we're going to set
color equals V color okay I'll just do
that over here right after this one to
override it
f5 okay so here we get a black triangle
which isn't right that's because I
forgot to actually set the color
Portwood right you guys probably thought
that my awesome buffer like layout code
just wasn't right but that's not
actually it is actually in fact working
because I wrote it so you know alright
there we have a pink triangle pretty
cool
last thing I'll do is actually just
change the color right so the color of
this vertex
I'll leave is pink the color of this
vertex I will set to like blue or
something so I'll get rid of this and
these are very harsh colors obviously
I'm not trying to be like an artist in
this case and then I guess what's there
maybe one of them to like yellow or
something let's hit f5 and see what
happens
okay so now we have actually defined
Vettes calls where pink yellow and green
blue before I can't I can't honestly I
can't commit this code cause it just
looks like absolute trash so what I'll
do is make some I'll make it just look
nicer
so we'll say point eight and point two
just so that we're not kind of going all
the way actually this it needs to be
pointy
so we'll say point eight I'm just
scaling the colors down a little bit so
they're not as harsh because like
honestly like and adding a bit more of
other colors in because otherwise like
it just as you saw just looks so bad I
really kind of hate it this will make it
look a lot nicer so let's just hit f5
and see what happens I need to get that
permission on t-shirt because apparently
it's my favorite catchphrase ever ever
okay beautiful
there we have our triangle with Olivet
has cars working all of this stuff is
now you know the layout so we're all
working correctly obviously what we
actually needed to do is call this set
layout layout okay and I guess
what we can do just to be really cool is
just to make sure that works
is just to make sure that we kind of get
the layout from the vertex buffer this
is not gonna work
because it's constantly and we don't
allow consciousness that's fun
we definitely should wait a constant
iterative to make that happen which I
don't know I thought that that would
kind of just work but I guess not so I
guess we need to also return a Const
iterator which is you know fun Const
Const yeah I guess that that should
would work okay done
and I'll do I'll actually put that in
here just to make sure that we can't
even access that way I think so this
actually gets destroyed in this case
after we've said it so now it should be
stored in the other thing and I guess
that obviously you probably brings out
into a variable before putting it here
but for fun I'll just leave it here
let's hit f5 and see what happens yep
that's it that's my phrase everything
works beautiful and then finally just to
clean it up and make it super nice I'll
just do order Const or our reference
layout equals that and I'll just pop
this in here and just check that card
and then now it's like ready to commit
and it will look nice
okay that's it so that is Buffalo outs
this is very powerful what I've just
written right like this stuff is really
nice it's really satisfying to have a
system like this in your engine because
that way you can just be really nice in
the script you can see that you can
visually see it'll out right I look over
here what do I see you know that three a
position of Veck for a color now float
three a position float for a color
everything's here in exactly the same
way that it appears here which is just
amazing right that's the kind of stuff
you want you don't want to be doing what
fiddling with numbers working out
strides doing all that stuff yourself
and no you describe your data in this
way it's going to be acceptable for
DirectX it's gonna be acceptable for
OpenGL everything is gonna work it's
gonna be beautiful
and
you know if you make an if you make a
mistake like this you know you know look
clearly it's different right and now
we'll you can see kind of how that works
so this is kind of the idea of what I
was kind of getting out with nice
elegant code kinda like that English
essay hopefully that makes sense and I
hope that you guys can learn something
from this now next time again I do want
to move this into vertex alright
and then this actual stuff this actual
kit this actual what figuring out these
vertex rip pointers that will be in the
OpenGL vertex array like you know class
so that'll be all kind of done through
there anyway I hope you guys enjoy this
video if you did even hit the like
button you helped small the stereos by
going over to patreon icon for session
the Cherno please help support this
series if you liked about episode
because all the support from all those
people is what makes this kind of stuff
possible now if you do want to kind of
skip ahead and see what I've written and
you don't got like a full PPR and
eruption it off a few times probably
will make a video like specifically
showing it off sometime this week maybe
but if you want access to that source
code just right now today you can just
go ahead and go to patreon don't go 4/2
turner helps about Sirius and you will
get access to that now let me know what
you thought what you thought of this
whole kind of buffer layout um I quite
like this way of dealing with it I
probably wouldn't even a gunner I feel
like there's probably no better way
they're gonna do this unless you
actually maybe like I don't know it's
weird what you could do is obviously
pause the shader and then just figure
out what it is cuz indirect tax they're
linked anyway but if you pass the shader
and you just kind of figure out what
your actual be is actually your arm and
you automatically set and validate and
the Buffalo out like that maybe that
would be even more robust because that
way there'd be zero code duplication and
the layout would be actually
automatically figured out from the
shader but aside from doing and stuff
like this but I don't feel like that's
necessary to be honest you get the stuff
right and you can have a vertex buffer
and your shader kind of laid out
correctly and and everything should just
work so let me know what you thought in
the comments section below hopefully I
taught you guys something new and you
kind of um
I'm now able to just write more elegant
card that's my heart
but anyway next time as I said about X
arrays we want to kind of get on with
that and actually moved some of this
code that we've written here today in
the application class need to vet x-rays
as you can see it's dark outside because
that's how long this episode's been
going for I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]